all it takes is one bad day
[Music]
Gotham we are almost done with season
four and we have one bad day so we're
following up a little bit more without
spoilers you should know that I'm
following up a little bit more with
Jeremiah what he's up to trying to blow
up the city we actually have quite a few
characters brought into this one there's
some focus on Harvey we've got Selina
we've got oz while we've got scarecrow
we've got butch we've got Barbara we've
got Tabitha we it's a mess of characters
in this one Edie
leave Lucius it seems like everybody's
on hand so why am i underwhelmed I
thought I think probably a lot of it
just has to do with the fact that I am
just not loving Jeremiah I think maybe
it would have worked better if they had
had more distance more time between when
Jerome exited and when Jeremiah kind of
took over they get like an episode maybe
two I can't remember now after Jerome
died before they really started to zoom
in on Jeremiah and I really feel like
some more time what a benefit this cuz
it just makes it all the easier for me
to compare the two and realize how much
more I like Jerome to reiterate some
things I it's not that I think Jeremiah
is bad it's and I like the fact that
there's an emphasis on his intelligence
and his mind and his intellect because
the the Joker is often intended to be
very smart but is rare that rarely kind
of translate so most of the the
adaptations of the kids especially in
live-action yet at the same time he's
just he's not as much fun I mean I
appreciate that he killed off Jerome's
followers I think Jerome as a character
made that work
you know the whole sort of cult of
personality thing Jeremiah does not have
as potent a personality and and even
though I feel like it kinda worked for
Jerome at the same time his actual
followers were one of the less
interesting things he had going on so
just burning them off haha see what I
did there was probably a good call so
that worked well I did you know what was
the highlight for me I really liked
Harvey's moments I liked him going in to
deal with that bomb I liked his fear at
having to make this decision
I loved both his reaction and how the
camera and the scene is allowed to
linger after he he you know makes his
choice which which wire do I do I deal
with and he picks one he doesn't blow up
he lets out this sigh you can hear it's
it's like he wants to cry this sort of
sort of thing that comes out of him and
and the camera just lingers we don't
immediately cut away it's really good
that's a really good moment I liked some
of the stuff with with Bruce I like this
kids grown on me and and the Alfred
stuff that worked decently so well
though Selina
I liked her stuff I really do feel like
they but I hate even suggesting this but
I'm certain to think maybe they should
have just killed Oswald previously they
really don't seem to know what to do
with him and I'm not enjoying watching
him just keep coming up with these
fly-by-night schemes that don't pan out
it's that's is not enjoyable to me I I
feel like they needed to take him off
the board for a while you know a bit
like how for a big stretch of season two
I think he was in Arkham like for a
significant stretch of time
he was he was out of the game he was
doing something else and it seems like
we've just had for the majority of the
season he's out he's trying to get power
back but it's just not working and I'm
not I'm just I'm not enjoying watching
that particularly Barbara was a little
more fun this time I'm starting to get
her feel her vibe back she felt a little
more like the Barbara I love that said
the fact that she now has a team of
assassins didn't really seem to enter
into things which makes me really
question what the point of any of that
was we've now got Ra's al Ghul teaming
with Jeremiah I'm just gonna kind of
shrug at that right now hopefully
something more interesting well-well
come out of that i i appreciate some
elements of this I appreciate the bits
that it pulled from The Killing Joke the
entire one bad day concept certain
elements of what Jeremiah does to try
and dry Bruce nuts is similar to what
the Joker puts Gordon through in The
Killing Joke so I appreciate that
I recognize it but doing a homage to a
well-written piece of earlier material
doesn't automatically make me think oh
so this is a well-written piece of
material because I'm just I don't know
guys you know ed Lee that I'm still
finding that interesting if that does
become flat-out that you know she is
just using him and we find that out for
certain it's probably gonna be on well
either that'll happen or he'll decide
he'll decide in his own hedge that must
be what she's doing him that'll be the
split I'm not particularly interested in
seeing either of those options play out
I and I also I consider this spoilers
for the next episode so yeah these bombs
are still gonna go off maybe on the way
Jeremiah originally planned but there's
still gonna be bombs going off we're
gonna be getting we're gonna be leaving
with Cataclysm and
man's lamb we are we are getting a
reshaped Gotham that's totally gonna be
what happens and assuming the show comes
back because I don't show to check this
I don't know if it's officially gotten
and next season renewal or not I did
hear Fox just canceled Brooklyn
nine-nine which I'm not happy about but
in any case assuming that it does get a
next season
this is doing no-man's land or some
variant of it is the kind of thing that
I think the show kind of needs right now
it's starting to fall into ruts a little
bit with how often the city is
threatened by something that detonates
whether it's detonating a gas in the air
or it's an actual explosion or whatever
and how often you know the the same
people are just cycling through who's in
control of of organized crime in Gotham
and they just seem to be taking it in
turns and I'm just I'm ready for a
shake-up so I'm still this this season
overall I would say it's the weakest
season since season one almost
definitely whether or not I consider to
overall be weaker than season one might
come down to next week's episodes the
the season finale we'll see
this wasn't a bad season overall but it
really did Peter out it's lost a lot of
momentum and and it didn't start great
either so there was a stretch in the
middle that was working really well but
right now I don't know I'm just kind of
ready for this season to be done and
that's just kind of where I'm at so
latest episode of Gotham what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all that
stuff to do you can support me on
patreon if you want to try and make all
this stuff possibly better than it
already is I have t-shirts and a Twitter
and a podcast and links for all the
stuff is down on this
so until next time Council's adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]